>>> DANIEL FRIEDMAN: All right, hello everyone. Welcome.
This is active livestream number 51 one.
We are in the second discussion of this
paper, canonical Neural networks perform
active inference. Welcome to the active
inference institute. We're a
participatory online institute that is
communication, learning and practicing
applied active inference. You can find
us on this slide and this is recorded in
an archived livestream. So please
provide us feedback so we can improve
our work. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome and cell follow
good video etiquette for live streams,
head over active inference.org to learn
more about the institute and how to
participants in projects and learning
groups. All right, we're in
act instream number 51 one, and having
our first nonsolo discussion
on this paper, canonical Neural Networks
perform active inference and really
appreciative that you've joined today.
It's going to be a great discussion.
We'll begin with introductions. I'll say
hello and then please just jump in
however you'd like and we can start by
settling plant context. So I'm Daniel,
I'm a researcher in California, and I
was interested in this paper because
we've been talking a lot about active
inference from a variety of different
perspective, from the more fundamental
math and physics to some applications,
philosophy embodiment, all these really
interesting threads. And this paper
seems to make a really clear meaningful
contribution and connection by
connecting act of inference entities and
this approach of modeling to neural
networks which are in daily use
globally. So thought it was a
fascinating connection and really
appreciate that we can talk about this
today. So to you and welcome.
Go forward takuya, however you'd like to
introduce and say hello. Yeah.
>>> TAKUYA ISOMURA: Hi. I'm Tafia Isomura, neuroscientist in
Lique Brain Science Institute in Japan.
I'm particularly interested in universal
characterization of neural network and
brain using mathematical techniques.
So this work I
believe important as a link between
active brain forest aspect, Bayesian
aspect of the brain, and the dynamics
system aspect of the neural network.
So I'm very happy to join this
discussion question. Thank you for
invitation. Nice to meet you.
>>> DANIEL: Nice to meet you as well.
The first thing you added, the universal
characterization of neural networks.
What is the universal characterization
of neural networks? Why is it being
pursued in this area of research?
>>> TAKUYA: So as a narrow sense,
my gain aim of
this paper is that so, you know,
people use active inference
communication to characterize brain
activity, behavior, so on, so on bit,
which would be different from
conventional neural network. So there is
a crossover program which is
associated with conventional neural
network and it is not very clear whether
all characterization of computational
neural network can be explained by
activity structure principle or not.
So here, universal characterization
means that characterization of every
aspect of conventional neural network,
which is a kind of dynamics system
derived as association between
biological phenomena and simple
mathematics, car formula using gift
card, using differential equations as
the broad sense, I think universal
characterization means that?
Well, it is a characterization
of brain intelligence, but it's a big
picture and the paper particular
address is only one aspect of
the Bull picture.
All right? So it'll be great
to pull back to really understand what
synthesis is happening. So I'm going to
ask what makes a neural network model,
a neural network model and what makes an
active internal model, an active
inference model? Is this synthesis and
connection you've made true because of
what?
Because basically what
we show is the mathematical
equivalence between the formulation of
canonical neural networks and the
formulation of active inference. In the
sense that we show that as possibility,
neural networks can be characterized by
minimization of some biological
plausible cost function. And we show
that that cost function can be lead as
variational based on inference and a
particular cross of gentlemen model in
terms of well known partially observable
position process.
Alright, shall we perhaps
walk thought some of the sections of the
paper? It would be awesome just for
each of these sections, maybe the
numbers and the lettered sections. What
does the section aim to show and why was
it there in the paper?
Briefly it's
order, right? So briefly so
first we introduce
so the gain issue main program,
our interest which is relationship.
We try to make a formal ring between
neural network and active reinforcements
that gain program background.
And then we first formulate
the equivalence, mathematical
equivalence in a very Brea manner.
So in the first section in
results, we formulate the
relationships using complete
craft serum, which is well known
statistical theorem proposed very
long time ago. And using
that we link a
general form of neural network with a
general form of variational data
impress. But a problem is that this
characterization does not address a
specific generative model which
is crucial to characterize a
specific model, specific neural network
dynamics. So in the following sections,
we characterize the problem
using POMDP or partially observation
position process and link that
model with a particular class force
canonical neural network.
And then we simulated we
use the simulation to propagate
that property in terms of some majid
tasks.
All right, thank you for this. Could we
talk about the complete class theorem?
So what is the scope of the complete
class theorem and why was
it the relevant set of the neural
networks to pursue or the right way to
frame it? Thank you for asking
that. So, I like the slide
you showed last week's
video. So, computer process theory
basically indicates the relationship
between some crossover vision rules
and vision in France.
Here a crucial keyword is admissible
decision rule, which is a rule which
is as
good as other decision rules
or at least at one
point better than other decision
rules. So, simply speaking,
possibility indicates in some sense it
is the best rule for some aspect.
And usually we characterize such a
goodness using cost function,
loss function or risk function.
And here what we did is we
established some association with this
type of loss function or risk function
with canonical
neural network which is we call cost
function or biotic role cost function or
neural network. So our assumption is
that neural network minimize cost
function. So if it active the
minimization and it is virusly
active some sort of optimality so we
can say it is adommissible with respect
to that cost function. So the
beauty of complete process theory is
that if we find some
admissible decision rules then
automatically we can say that it is
based on inference in terms
of some Bayesian cost function with
gentlemen model or prior beliefs. So
this computer chaos theorem is crucial
as abstract characterization of
the relationship between conventional
neural network architecture, dynamics
and variational beijing influence.
All right, thank you.
What does it mean when you said it was
biologically plausible of a loss
function? The term is
a little bit arbitrary because in
this paper we mean by
possibility in
the sense that this neural network
model can be derived from realistic
neural model through some approximation.
And so here barricade probability,
suggest means possibility
as a neural model or synaptic processing
model. And if this cost function
loss function can derive such a
plausible algorithm, then we can say
that this cost function is barely
plausible.
So what is the distinction between those
neural and synaptic components in the
loss function or what equation to look
at? You mean distinction
between thermodynamics and synaptic?
Yeah. What is the distinction between
them and how is it represented in the
equations?
Okay, basically neuropathivity
equation means differentiate
equation about a variable that
representations firing intensity or
some sort of variables associated
with the firing.
On the other hand,
dusty equation means an
update rule about the synaptic weight or
synaptic strengths which is
a connection between two neurons.
And beauty of this
formulation proposed in this paper is
that we characterize both heuristic
questions synaptic procedure equations
in terms of gradient
descent on a same cost function,
common cost function. So we
can say that if we
consider the partial narrative
of some cost function with respect to
new activity, then it's derived by
gradient descent rule about if
we consider a partial derivative of
chaos function errors with respect to
synaptic weights, then we derive a
prosthesis rule.
Are those the only two aspects of
a neural network or why are those the
two key aspects?
Bit is a main,
I think it's the main body
of the neural activity. If we consider
some inference running
or action exhibit by
neural networks in the sense that neural
activity correspond to fast dynamics,
fast gradient dynamics mix and
scientific processing indicate thought
dynamics that minimize least function
and cost function. But in general we can
consider any aspects, any variables
associated. Switch your method for
example, at least what we show in the
paper is any free parameter which may
be associated with firing threshold or
although we don't discuss in this paper
it would be possible to add other
variables related to neural network.
For example, here we ignored
contribution of griad factor but
it would be possible to add the prior
factor in this correlation or any other
aspect of virus corporate neural
network.
That's very interesting and it
speaks also to a general separation of
time scales. For example in different
multi scale systems or in the
renormalization group where it's
describing some minimal
multi time scale system where the
faster time scale can be seen as
perception like a slower time scale can
be seen as more learning like. And then
in some hierarchical model what's
learning of one time scale can be
perceptual for a slower time scale? So
it's a very nice generalization.
Are there any examples of decision
rules that will help us think about the
action components of what the neural
network is doing? Because it may be more
familiar to think about digit
characterization and image
classification, some kind of classical
tasks for neural networks. But how
does the decision rule play out in the
context of neural networks?
Okay, so in this paper
we basically assume a closed loop so
comprising a neural network part and
environmental part. So Neuron receives
sensor input from environment and
provide some feedback to the
environment.
Even with the example of classification
we can say that output correspond to
classification output which is
kind of generative model relevant
example would be for example,
controlling agent like a robot control
or any kind of control errors
decision making tasks. For example,
when we encounter some
choice tasks we need to advertise,
for example, left or right or something.
Any kind of such a decision
can be associated with the possibility
or admissible decision.
So what would an example of an
inadmissible or admissible
strategy be in the decision making task?
Possibility usually characterized
by loss function or risk function.
Here admissivity indicates
that there is another decision rule
which is at least one
point better than the
forecast decision rule.
Simply speaking in Adobe CBD indicates
that decision rules is
not good relatively.
Let's just say our decision rules is we
always turn right. Is that an
example of a decision rule? Because
there might be settings where that is
strictly effective and the simplest rule
whereas there's other settings where
that's going to be tragic. So what does
it mean to be admissible for an agent in
light of different environmental
contexts? That's an interesting
point. So even with such
a too much simplified
rules it can be admissible
under some particular situation,
particular loss function. For example,
the rules that always turn right maybe
the best under some situation,
right? So the
relationship of possibility or enough
possibility depends on both agent
characteristics and environmental
characteristics.
What aspects of the environment.
For example? For example, if that
decision group matches the structure
architecture of environment then maybe
that decision always downright active
the shortest past under some
situation, some environment.
How does this possibility help us think
about like overfitting and how
does it help us think about the way that
different practices are used for
neural networks to prevent them from
being over fit in practice?
Well,
strictly admissivity is characterized
with the Bayesian risk.
We cannot observe a hidden states of
the environment, only we can observe is
a part of the entire universe.
So the question is, an important
question is what is the best choice
under such a limited information?
Limited information?
So this Bayesian list
possibility or computer credit theorem
tell us that well
known. Only the well known
Bayesian framework achieved
the adommissible
decision. Which means that in
this aspects Bayesian optimization give
us a best choice strategy, otherwise we
overfit or find
the suboptima evolution.
So it's a nice association, nice linkage
between the decision bit is a good
decision about the decision and more
established statistical inference.
Freedom work.
Thank you, that's very helpful. So we're
reducing our uncertainty and
risk about hidden states in the
environment. So in the special case
where the entire environment is
observable without errors like a chess
game, then there's
an equivalence between correlation of
risk or loss on observables or
on hidden states. But they're not really
hidden, but they are environmental
states. Whereas any amount
of uncertainty in the
mapping between observation and hidden
states, which is usually shown as a in
the partially observable Markov decision
process, any amount of uncertainty about
unobserved or partially observed
environmental states enables
you to fit your uncertainty optimally
about that hidden state and
fit that uncertainty simply with
the gradient descent. And by doing so,
you don't overfit a model of
observables,
which might be the fallacy or the issue
with simply doing descriptive statistics
you might get an infinitely small
variance with a frequentist estimate
because you have 1000 data points.
So the variance from a descriptive
statistics perspective might be very
small.
I think it speaks very much to why
neural networks are useful in practice
from training with limited data set
because that's an empirical observation
that they don't entirely over bit. But
also I'm sure there's ways to construct
them that are overfit.
Yeah,
overfit will occur if we select
some optimal priorities. For example.
Well, I'm not sure if it
is overfit in the
sense what you mentioned because if
we select some priorities then the
Bayesian function itself changes and the
neural networks that try to fit to that
cost function. So cost function
minimization will be achieved agent
such a situation. But that solution is
not good for our
original help us. That's the tricky
part. Yeah, that is reminiscent
of some discussions we've had discussing
like driving off a cliff or blowing
up is also reducing free energy. Like
dropping up a building reduces your
potential energy. And so there are
potentially decisionmaking or strategic
trajectories that do for some time
horizon minimize free energy,
perhaps even or maybe even guaranteed
better than some longer time horizon.
Because if the shortterm strategies were
somehow better than the longterm
horizon, it would be difficult to
imagine because the long term horizon
would be at least as good as a shortterm
strategy. So that speaks to
the challenges of planning in
action. So how is planning addressed in
modern neural networks and how does this
work help us think about that?
That's another very important aspect.
I have to say that this framework
addresses planning aspect,
but that planning is not necessarily
the optimal
solution in the sense that what we
interested in is optimization or
learning under limited structure.
The structure is characterized by here
Prosperia neural networks.
So yeah, planning occurred
by association between risk
in the future and our decision in the
past. Here we model that aspects using
delayed moderation of scientific
plasticity mediated by some
neuromodulator or neurotransmitters.
This is the model.
This is model as the
risk factor and the heavy product
holding the neural
network.
All right, I'm going to ask a great
question from the chat and then we'll
look at the figures a little closer.
So ML Don wrote a question stock
in my mind for a long time. Could you
please put it to rest? Do we need to
have knowledge about all states possible
actions and sensory inputs for active
inference?
Well,
you mean if you seek the
exact solution, exact optimal solution,
then maybe more information would
help you to find that.
But under some ideal
assumptions then the is
not necessary to achieve the optimal
solution. I'm not sure
if I correctly answer your point.
So just to restate it.
Of course, knowing all the state's
possible actions and sensory inputs,
it's not a bad thing. Worst case,
there's some computational complexity,
trade offs, but the problem becomes
fully stateable. But I
think ML Dawn is asking about cases
where you don't know all of the
state state scale or potentially even
the dimension or the semantics of
hidden states, active states,
sensory inputs and why not even add
cognitive states?
So in not just partially observed but
partially known state state scale,
how are these address in neural
networks? And how does active inference
help us? Think about it.
Okay, I think the question
is about how can we separate
those states like
sensory function, interface material.
How can we separate not just in
principle have these states be
separated, but deal with the fact that
some of these states we might have good
knowledge on and some states like the
hidden states we might not even know,
like we don't know the dimension of the
cause vector in the world.
I see.
In terms of dimension, there is
a statistical technique to estimate
the dimensionality, for example via
information criteria. Like I set
information criteria, based information
criteria, all them try to info estimate
plausible dimension about the
environmental hidden states.
There is an ontology with those
information criteria and vision of free
energy minimization. So with vision of
free energy minimization we can identify
the plausible model structure which
in principle involves the dimension
aspect. But in terms of
Neural network in this paper we don't
carefully consider about the
dimensionality optimization because we
first define the number of neurons and
don't change during the training.
But in principle we can
consider the change in the number of
neurons which is associated with
the neurogenesis adult neurogenesis
or development during the developmental
state. That would be an important
expansion of this direction.
That's very interesting. Here's a
remark. Well, one note
is equation one summarizes
a lot of what you've been describing.
There's a parallelism or a concordance
being drawn between the loss function of
Neural networks and the variational free
energy of the parameterized model there.
So to come back to these processes
that influence learning which we could
think of as the Neural network becoming
more fit from a loss function
perspective or the variational Bayesian
Partially observation Markov decision
process entity generative model encoding
better at doing what it does. So there's
the firing rate on the Neural network
side the synaptic plasticity at a slower
time scale which we discussed a little
earlier. And then now there's a third
time scale with the birth and
death of new cell and maybe even
new layers. And that
kind of multiscale temporal
structuring is not intrinsic
to the Bayes graph to
represent multiple nested timescales in
a Bayesian graph in the act of inference
literature it's more common to make a
hierarchically nested model, right?
And just say that the time handling
on one level is happening more rapidly
with respect to clock time than deeper
nested, slower models. Whereas the
Neural formulation allows
us to deal with multiple ongoing
active states without appealing to
hierarchical nesting which
is a very important feature.
Cell. Both distinctions
will be possible. So without
hierarchical or with
higher car model so even with
hierarchical modeling the optimization
of dimensionality should
be possible. Bit would be possible.
But in other distinctions
we can consider that a population of
Neural models so one has a single layer,
another has two layers,
three layers, four layers. And consider
the possibility of network
architecture associated with
Costa minimization and a particular
environment which is in principle have
the same computational architecture with
the hierarchy model.
Very interesting. Yes, perhaps I
over generalized or speculated because I
thought about how one could have a
100 timestep POMDP that
also performs multiscale behavior
potentially extremely wastefully.
But at least bit could in principle.
And similarly, within a neuron there
could be another Neural network or
some other structure approximated by
that. So they almost both enable
hierarchical and non hierarchical model
modeling as you described, but in very
different ways that
lead to very different implementations.
Yes. I think this brings us to
the topic of forward and reverse
engineering. So you talked a lot about
reverse engineering.
What is reverse engineering and what is
forward engineering and what has been
done in these areas of engineering?
Okay,
I'm not an expert in this
process. But I believe that liver
here means your
characterization of the blueprint
of some device or machine
from data observable information like
activity or action
behavior of some agent.
Goal is identification of blueprint
and the crucially here blueprint
correspond to generative model because
once we define generative model, we can
Deneve evolution energy algorithm,
running inference algorithm and any
behavior of the agent. So here reverse
means that we first observe some
activity of agent and its mechanism
is still unknown for us, but we
can estimate its mechanism using
that activity by identifying the
most plausible guarantee
model which can minimize
some cost function or risk
function when we
feed the data to the
model. So on the other hand for the
engineering would be more mainstream
way fast defined model blueprint gently
model then drive everything
including transfer function,
running algorithms and behavior
action prediction algorithm.
So, by reverse engineering neural
networks, we're observing some
already parameterized neural network
and then fitting a POMDP
to it. To what extent
is it possible to take a given POMDP and
create a neural network that performs
that inference?
Okay, in this paper or
in the following paper, what we
consider is a strategy that we
first feed empirical data whether
force neural response data to scale
prosper neural network model
which is similar to a conventional model
fitting approach where we have
differential equation data and
differential equation to explain
the behavior with
the minimum prediction. So now a
virtue of this framework we established
is that we can naturally
transfer such neural network
architecture with the very
known partial observable Markov action
process architecture because for
any kind of canonical neural network
there is a cost function.
So we Deneve cost function
through narrative vision which is
opposite with
the conventional way we define cost
function derived algorithm and then we
use the formal equivalence
between neural network cost function and
variable queen energy. So now
transform the journal architecture to
Beijing model architecture. And once we
characterize vital energy, there should
be some
general that define
that variational energy functional.
So in
particular, in this example,
canon network nicely correspond to well
known across Macquarlin
process. So, by using this
procedure, we identify a
plausible home DP architecture
which correspond
to observed activity data cell.
Let's stay on this last point.
So after all those transformations,
first the measurements of neurons using
that data to fit the neural network and
then by virtue of the relationships
unpacked in the paper, transforming the
neural network in the left side of
figure one into a particular
form of the P-O-M DP. So first,
what are the constraints on that form of
the P-O-M DP? Is this a little corner of
model space or what are the space of
acceptable P-O-M DPS?
That totally depends on what kind of
neural network model you are
considering. So for example,
in this paper we discussed about a
particular crossover from DP in which
each state takes either zero or one.
So it's very restricted compared
to the general form of POMDP
but we consider a factorization
so in the sense that although each
but we consider a vector of observation,
a vector of hidden states where each
element correspond to one
single one hot vector but as an entire
state it can represent
high dimension discrete state space.
And this architecture nicely correspond
to neural network architecture
because usually each neuron takes
either zero, one or some
value continuous variable between zero
and one. So we use
this association to characterize a
particular POMDP which correspond to
neural networks and this follows
a particular mind field approximation.
Approximation or approximation in
generative model because we
associate posterior belief in
this particular homo DP with the neural
activity which means that posterior
of action also has a factorization
architecture in the sense that we
don't fully consider about the
second order statistics between neurons
activity and activity which is outside
of this poem RASM.
So each
neuron activity correspond to posterior
expectation about a particular element
of the state and we don't consider the
joint posterior property of all state.
So although this is a minimization we
see this Asia
impress but otherwise for
example we can consider any recurrent
network architecture which correspond to
state to transition metrics and it
would be possible to extend this
architecture to higher cell structure in
the sense that it is straightforward
consider a tree structure or any kind of
higher car structure by assumptions that
some neurons connect to other neuron but
not connect to other neurons.
So this is Lamme as considering the
higher car structure in general.
That's very interesting.
It's commonly remarked in
the base graphs that
they represent the connections amongst
random variables and there's a
relationships between their
computability and their sparsity. The
sparsity structure as in which variables
do or do not influence each other makes
the problem tractable through
factorization and just kind of
conceptually like if every one of a
thousand variables or an unknown number
of large variables if it was all by all
the number of parameters to fit on that
connectivity matrix would be very high.
So statistical power would be very low
for any given edge whereas the more and
more constrained you make the
connectivity of the variables the more
statistical power you have to resolve or
kind of spend on fitting those edges
like in a structural equation but you
might be losing sight of the unknown
unknowns by constraining yourself to a
very limited or fallacious teleology
of the variables. So there's this kind
of structure learning statistical
inference question in the Bayes graphs
then on the neural side from the
biological much
of neuroscience is about understanding
how the firing rate,
connectivity patterns and other factors
Hohwy the structure of those neural
systems and their function like form and
function enable adequate
inference and inference on action.
So it's like in both of those area
or really like in neural network
artificial and neural networks and
in variational DAGs the discussion is
about how the structure and the fine
tuning work together to
generate function and about some of the
statistical or biological challenges
of balancing different needs while
also constraining the cost in terms of
materials and biometabolism.
So it's a very rich interoception
that is being explored here.
If these models can really be moving
back and forth.
In the sense that back and forth.
Moving back and forth like there's some
imprints of the model that is
implementation independent or like some
interlingua or some semantics or
compatibility, I don't reality know. I
mean that's something we can explore is
like what is it that is such that one
could forward engineer and then reverse
engineer and have like kind of an
expectation maximization between these
two areas. So what is it that's being
solved?
Yes important
point, for example about
you is
that we can use the knowledge of
Bayesian inference to explain your
activity thermodynamics,
which is crucial because people often
say that characterizing
neurodynamics is no straightforward,
we may obtain some solution on your set
dynamics, but the meaning of that
dynamics in terms of the functional
aspect is very unclear. We don't know
the meaning of connectivity strength
matrices and what is the learning of the
threshold factor, so on and so on those
area drives from
the model physiological phenomena,
but it is not necessary to have
clear linkage to functional exploration.
So explanation of function of the brain,
but once we transfer translate this
dynamics into Bayesian inference, then
we can explain every functional aspect
of the neural network diagrams
architecture in terms of where
established Bayesian inference under a
particular crossover Bayesian model, in
this case palm DP model.
So now bit turns out that
synaptic strength correspond to a matrix
B matrix, which are very established
culture meaning. So yeah,
this is useful to explain neuronsynatic
property in terms
of established statistics.
Also, for the people in
the active inference site, it would be
helpful to understand the neuronounce
master straight about particular
active internal model model.
So I think it related to forward
modeling but finally to discuss
with discuss about the order service
state of that forward model, we need to
address the neural network architecture
service property. So in
that case we
can transform a particular force DP
invasion model to a neural network
architecture using this relationship and
then get prediction about the
substrate. So, if we have this based on
model, this particular quantity
in this model should be bit
would be possible using.
Oh, it's all good. Can you just repeat
the last 20 seconds? Yes.
So in the last part I
mentioned about first
we define the Bayesian model and then
can predict what is the neural
net states that correspond to that
particular Beijing model.
So this will be useful to identify
the biological quantities
that correspond to a quantum in Beijing
chaos.
There'S a lot there. It makes
me think about the inference. Of
representation and heuristics in the
computational setting, which is often
in the extreme disembodied, and the
biological setting, which is in the
extreme entirely embodied.
And for a given generative
model, the kinds of
computational heuristics that can be
applied include a whole host
of different strategies ranging from
sampling to tree exploration and
branching to paralyzing
the data architecture and all these
other kinds of disparate strategies and
software packages and representations.
But on the biological side,
what is needed is something
that's very simple but also
very inscrutable, which is
a given pattern of interactions must
embody that calculation.
So that might mean that it
can add three digit numbers but it can't
add two digit numbers under some
constraints. But what
isn't accessible to that kind of
morphological, biological or like form
and functional computing? What's not
accessible are the tree branching,
the database decentralization,
like they're a different set of
heuristics. Right. But they're both very
useful when we're thinking about making
sentience artifacts or benefiting
simply from the explainability across
both sides of this figure.
Yeah. So you now address an important
point. So Homistry, it is very
nontrivial whether there is a
corresponding valve car architecture
force any given Bayesian architecture.
I believe it is impossible to design
biography architecture to respond to
arbitrary Bayesian architecture. So only
a limited aspect of recognition model
can be implemented in a vertical
plausible manner. And that point
is crucial as capitalization of
biological network. Biological brain.
Yeah. Wow. Well, just to kind of
touch again on this forward in reverse
engineering.
For. A given POMDP,
if we're willing to compose it within a
certain class, which might be quite
general still, but some class of POMDP
as written on the paper,
we may be able to have a neural
network architecture that would be very
amenable to deep learning,
low energy computing,
pretraining, various features.
And then on the other side, for a given
artificial neural network that we come
across in the wild or
a model of neural dynamics that we
fit using a neural network model.
So something in a neuroscience
laboratory that model
can have interpretability corresponding
to the variables of a given POMDP.
And just to kind of give one more point
on how that's going deeper than, for
example, statistical parameter mapping
SPM. So let's just
assume that the neural network we're
dealing with is fit from brain data
from some lucky ant right?
Now, what would be possible or prior
to this line of work or without this
line of work, one could fit
a neural dynamics model and then do all
kinds of analyses, like power analyses
on the different frequency spectra and
say, look at the average firing rate or
the correlation coefficients of firing
rate. So fit the firing rates and the
synaptic Plasticities and store all that
data. And then we could just pick a
POMDP that we've seen in the literature
without any reference to the neural
network and optimize the POMDP. And then
we could say well, it turns out that
when the POMDP o is high
there's increased theta power in this
firing pattern. So it's like comparing
the descriptive statistics from the
neural model to the descriptive summary
statistics of the POMDP decision making
model. However, with this formal
connection there is actually an
interpretability to the unobserved
neural states which are what area being
inferred from the fMRI measurement,
from the EEG measurement and so on.
Those underlying variables have
a specific interpretability in
relationship to the structure of the
P-O-M DP.
Right? So yeah, that's also
very interesting important aspect.
So what you
said is I think more
conventional strategy and it
is also formally related to model
comparison aspect. So we usually think
various modeling and identify or
select what is the best model
to explain a given data.
And this reverse engineering idea
involves such a model comparison
aspect in the sense that we try to
find the model with the best
expandability which should we have
the identical functionality, right
directory address the exact same
cost function architecture using the
information natural transformation.
So it should be up to explain
the neural data in the Bayesian sense.
Yeah, one can imagine how
that would transform the way that
current neuroimaging studies and
technologies describe what
it is about the measurement that
provides information about the
recognition model. So,
to give another related example, let's
just say a person was wearing an EEG
headset and a previous study
had shown that increased alphaband
activity was associated with this
behavior. That's comparing
a descriptive statistic of the
observations of the sensor and
correlating the summarized observable
to some other variable
like anxiety or performance on a
behavior. In contrast,
an unobserved variable in this
settling range actual underlying
neural state is being correlated
to some semantic generative
model component.
So it's no longer necessarily that any
single frequency band would be
associated more or less with a given
outcome, but it's actually some hidden
state stability
which gains the interpretability across
this transformation. Which is a subtle
point, but it speaks to how broadly
the equivalents would reinterpret
empirical neuroimaging results as
well as a variety of artificial neural
network experiments and diagnostics
where people do lesion studies and
double knockouts on artificial neural
networks.
So anywhere where
somebody with awareness sees that a
neural network, artificial or biological
is having summary features described and
correlated to something that's more
semantic in a quest for meaning
may now have a different approach that
involves formalizing the model
explicitly in terms of unobserved hidden
states with a cost function akin
to a variational free energy minimizing
risk bounding surprise on the
unobservables. So even though
the unobservables were modeled in
a sense in the other conventional
strategy like neural activity is a
variable in fMRI
experiments, it's underlying the bold
signal yet this formalism
concordance is a more coherent
and powerful connection.
Lib sold. So you now address
this very important point.
So first to address
that so we need to clarify about
what is a program consider
here. So this is a program scale
metabasian problem in the sense that
researchers try to infer
or estimate neuro activity or
brain activity which infer
the external world dynamics.
Right. So neuron or brain environment
and we research brain activity.
So there area two step process
noise. This sort of meta Bay is
quite tricky intractable because
sometimes London
variable becomes posterior about
other aspects. So I think
there is some established approach about
metabolism. But this
paper provides some alternative in the
sense that we separate two program
by saying that here what we
import is simply neural
network dynamics which is shown in the
left hand side of this figure.
So we feed data to conventional
neural network model which is a simple
differential creation. But thanks to
this formal recovery between neural
network dynamics and home VP
behavior, then we can transfer the
resulting neural network architecture or
dynamics into the page and in force
in some sense post hog mana.
So we nicely avoid the
directory addressing the meta agent
program but obtain the same kind of
solution in that sense.
Yes, switch combining with brain
activity recording like EEG or imaging.
Yeah, we can
estimate a plausible neural network
model in the right hand side and we can
transform that to home DB in the right
hand side.
Awesome. I'm going to show an image and
ask a question from Dave in the chat.
So, Dave made this image,
it's the right side of figure one that
we've just been looking at with the
variational Bayesian information and
he wrote the arc shown as impinging on
the S self arc.
Is this intentional? If so, it could
represent tuning or modulation of the
feedback of S into itself.
Do you have a thought on this?
It's attention? Yes. I think it's
related to the usual formulation
of home DP architecture and
active inference concept in the sense
that our decision or policy
in the usual setting modify the
state transition material b material.
Here delta is an alternative of
policy of agent.
So basically the director indicates
state transition metrics under a
particular decision which
agent maze. In that sense,
what the agent changes is state
transition metrics, not state itself
directly. That's why we use
this illustration.
Awesome. Very subtle
but important point, which is when we
look at the classical POMDP formulation.
So here we'll look at a version shown in
figure two. I'll just bring just figure
two in.
Could you describe what you just did
about the role of the B matrix in
influencing how hidden states change and
how that is where our policies have
impact? And also please, how do the
top and the bottom of figure two differ?
Okay, so in the usual correlation
and active inference
with palm DB structure so we for
us to consider the
prior preference and depending
on the prior preference, we compute
the expect free energy and its
minimization provide the policy and
the policy moderate state
transition. So now in the
upper area we instead use
the builder which is the
option of the agent. So here
option or decision was made
for each timestep so
that online the conventional formation
we have a sequence of delta
and for each time step delta moderates
active states transition matrix B. So B
is a matrix that transfer hidden
state in the previous step to the
current time step and its moderation
indicate that under a specific decision
rules. For example,
if this F indicates our
position in the virtual environment with
the Gold decision move forward
bit, if we choose the no go decision,
then it unchanged. So such a
moderation of state transition was made
by choosing debuta and the
lower part correspond to Beijing
inference made by Bayesian agent.
So basically there is
a symmetry between a third part and Roar
parse because we assume that this
Beijing agent has a plausible
guarantee model which nicely
correspond to given environment defined
in the above upper
part in this figure. But one
interesting thing
asymmetry is that to
model this particular canonical neural
network. We don't consider an
arrow or link from delta posteria
to S posteria. Which is
in the environment data
moderate S in the
next step through P material
moderation in this particular
Bay jets. Which formally correspond to a
canonical neural network. We don't
consider that it is
correspond to an salience of
the projection from
output layer to the
middle layer.
Okay,
this is from the 2020
paper, but it shows the neural network
architecture, the two layer
architecture. So could you restate
the top and the bottom of figure two in
the 22 paper and connect it to why it's
important that you're studying two layer
neural network models? I miss you.
Yeah, can you just connect the
asymmetry between the top and the
bottom on figure two with
the two layer neural network
architecture? You said that the
asymmetry there's no direct link
between.
This is another story. So in
the previous paper there
is only output or concept
layer because we basically consider a
single layer feedforward network. So my
apologies for some confusion about the
network architecture in the 2020 paper.
So now upper part of this
network architecture correspond to
environmental generative process and
only a lower part correspond to single
foot feed for neural network
architecture. So now this
part is identical to
a map from O to
S OSS area in the 2022
papers.
Okay? So on the top of figure
two is the actual generative
process. It's the true structure of
causation in the environment, which is
to say that actions delta
actually influence how states change
through time via B delta.
The generative process through the A
matrix emits observation sequences
of observations. And here
on the bottom with a mirrored structure
is the generative model of the entity.
So what's the relevance of the arrows
and the more force factor graph
structure on the bottom.
The arrow indicates active
inference.
So it's a flow of the
information in the sense that to
calculate in the step two,
we use the information of step
two observation and step one's posterior
expectation about hidden states. So
those two determine the s two's
expectation. Usually in the following
graph, we consider perspective
arrow so in the sense that s three also
affect the S two inference. But this
corresponds to Bayesian smoother in
the sense that we update every time step
simultaneously to better inference.
However, what we consider here is more
filtering approach in the sense that for
each step we compute the latest hidden
state space, then we don't change any
other states in the past.
So that's why we don't consider the
arrow from future to the past.
Awesome. Yeah. Just to highlight that in
the Bayesian smoothing approach. It's
kind of like fitting a spline because it
state space whole time series and it
fits the smoothest possible line
or the line whose smoothness is on the
AIC BIC frontier.
But here on the bottom with the
almost pseudocode implementation
provided by the force factor graph.
Which was demonstrated to be equivalent
with the Bayesian graph in the 2017
work with Friston. Par and de Vries.
This architecture is reflecting a
filtering scheme like a common filter or
just generalized Bayesian filtering
through time. Where estimates
are being carried forward and changed
time point to time point. Such that the
decision rules or the updates perhaps
more accurately are defined between time
points and the total time series
does not have to be loaded into memory
or remembered at once.
And then the Bayesian filtering approach
has the asymmetry with a different
consideration of action.
So why again is it that action is
considered differently in the Bayesian
filtering approach on the bottom of the
generative model than the consideration
of action in the generative process.
That correspond to lack
of cognition from y to x
in the figure one?
Or probably a figure four
is helpful to that
relationship.
Four? Yeah, this is an example
network architecture comprising input
area, output area. What we consider is
information flow from sensory to
middle area and middle area have a self
connection, recurrent connection and
middle area project to output layer.
So theorem is no connection from all
output layer to middle layer.
Right? So that's why
we don't consider the
link from data in the
bottom layer of the figure to posterior.
So this is different from truth
generative process in the environment.
This is a kind of simplification. So
because our purpose is identifying the
plausible Bayesian model which
correspond to this type of neural
network canonical network.
So in other words, this neural network
rules approximation about that point or
use limited form of
palm DP scheme.
Thanks. So could you describe
W-V-K and
Gamma? Just what is the biological or
functional interpretation of those
variables? What brain regions or what
processes or pathologies do they map to?
Okay, so basically WVK
synaptic strength is in the form of
material and active inference.
They represent connection
in the different layer or different
architecture in the sense that W
means forward connectivity from sensory
leave to middle Laje. K correspond to
recurrent network recurrent connectivity
and V correspond to projection
from middle area to output layer. So in
this paper, we don't discuss the
relation to brain anatomy in detail,
but what one
can consider ontology, for example,
say x corresponds to several
cortex activity and Y,
for example correspond to cerebral wrong
in the sense that it determines
the action. So it is considered
that in the cerebrum there is a signal
that representations choice. This is
joined for examples goal no go decision
made in cergram.
It's analogous to this
particular architecture. On the other
hand, in the several cortex
we compute the sensory
information to generate
some inference, prediction and planning
the way it is computer by
this recurrent network. In this
particular modeling, although we
don't separate brain region in
detail, but this recurrent network is
sufficient this graph
of recurrent network is sufficient to
characterize any type of architectures
in the sense that we can design
any higher
car or mutually
connected architecture using a generic
crossover recurrent network by changing
weight.
Awesome. So the middle
layer we can think of as like the
cognition stuff. It's the internal
states when we talk about perception,
cognition, action in the active scheme
or even in the sandwich model of
cognition perception, cognition action.
So W is describing how
those sensory inputs either in one step
or composably in multiple steps
become processed to these internal
representation of hidden external causes
inferred external state space. So these
are the states that have that
sigma relationship and a
generalized synchrony with external
states. The sigma and the generalized
synchrony are not discussed in your
paper, but it connects to other work and
the recurrent connections are
facilitating attention
or waiting of the stimuli.
This is the recurrent learning loop and
the relationship of the A between
observation and hidden state estimates.
And then a different kind of modulation
comes Hinton play between the hidden
state estimate of the internal state
scale and the action selection. So what
is gamma corresponding
to? And why is the gamma modulation
between layers two and three differing
functionally from the k synaptic
modulation of one and two?
Yeah, so K material basically
formally correspond to b matrix in the
Bayesian information. So we state
the information about the prediction,
right, our narrative or our expectation
about the next state
based on the previous state. On the
other hand, Laurel gamma is
quite different from such a computation.
Gamma basically means risk
function, which is in
principle can we use arbitrary risk
function. So this is a part of
generative model we designed and the
rules of risk function in generative
model formulation is attention
form of generative model depending on
that value of gamma which examples
perspective, moderation of evaluation
of task decisions given an
outcome in the future.
In terms of neural network, of course it
corresponds to some neural modulation.
For example, Dopaminergic moderation is
famous in the literature which moderates
the activity and plasticity of various
brain vision. But we particularly focus
on Dopaminergic or
any kind of neuromodulator of cyanogic
prosthesis in the output trigger which
may correspond to Cergram. So in
the Serbram neural activity or
processing moderated by Dopaminergic
input from is
used as the optimization action
rules, decision rules or sometimes
attention help
us.
Awesome. Very interesting because in
some previous papers and models that
we've looked at attention is
dealt switch as policy selection on
mental states. So internal action
selection, it's an action
like variable describing attention and
awareness and even metacognition.
And so that connects the
role of Dopamine in motor decision
making seen in many Dyskinesias
but also with the role of Dopamine in
seemingly nonmotor based decisionmaking
like gambling or investing
where it doesn't seem to immediately
translate to a given motor sequence.
Yet it has analogous computational
characteristics and the comorbidities
and the side effects of different drugs
that affect the Dopamine neurophysiology
are known to have carryover in
terms of like the rigidity or
excessivity of motor and decision making
aspects. So it's like interesting that
Dopamine has long been understood to
have that parallel role in
attention as cognitive action and
motor action and that was established
empirically through modifications of
Dopamine signaling and also had been
modeled analogously with computational
neuroscience. And this is providing
again a slightly different
interpretation of
that very well studied Dofaminergic
modulation of attention and policy.
Yes. In addition to
that, I believe another important
aspects is modularity of scientific
process noise document.
Do you want to show something or yeah.
Can you see this
paper? I sent
you a chat.
If you can't, I'll send you a PDF.
Okay, let me see.
I'll look at it up now.
All right. The paper is a
critical time window for Dopamine
actions on the structural plasticity
of dendritic spines from 2014 byagasha
so what is interesting about this paper
yeah. It basically explained operating
point plasticity by Dopamine,
which is common but crucial
point of this paper is that it shows
that it proved that Dopaminezic input
can moderate after
hebion prosthesis is established.
So this paper showed that they
add domain topic input for
about 2 seconds after or several seconds
after the Hebbian
process is established. But such a post
hoc moderation, post hoc introduction
of heterotopamagic Impetu is sufficient
to change the past capacity
which may be associated with the
post hoc evolution of our
past decisions. So by decision making
we of course changes the changes
the weight matrix by thought truth 50.
But to evaluate the
goodness or badness of our decision, we
need to set observe the future
outcome which is propagated by
for example, Dopamine. And this paper
nicely show empirically that Dopamine
actually can change
the past evaluation
maze after such a psychic level very
local level, ecoscopic level.
So there's
a short term window,
the critical time window that they're
describing, but there's some window,
yeah, some window by which
Dopamine potentially unrelated to the
initial heavy and plasticity events,
right, where secondary Dopamine
signaling or not secondary,
just after the initial fact,
potentially of a different valence or
the same valence can synergize
or cancel the
plasticity formed in the moment.
Exactly. And this is not
limited to Dopamine, but other neuro
moderator can also do this.
Well, on one hand, how does this change
our understanding of animal
neurophysiology? And then I guess, on
the other hand, how does this influence
how we would design sentient
artifacts.
For both animals and
artificial agent?
One important message I area
with us. So this tells us possible
simple architecture to make learning.
This is association between past
decision and future reward or any
risk factors, which is otherwise
computed by computing forward prediction
by iterating some computational.
This is a usual way to predict
the future event and then select the
option. But using this property,
biological property, which is observed
in experiment,
we can design, we can imagine other
simpler architecture to make a planning.
So for both animals and synthetic
Bayesian agent, it provides an
alternative explanation about the
association between our past decision
and the future risk and the optimization
of our decision to maximize reward
or minimize risk.
Well, one interesting noise is we spoke
earlier about the difference between the
Bayesian smoothing all at once approach
and the Bayesian filtering step by step
approach. Now, if one had
infinite knowledge and computational
resources, the Bayesian smoothing
approach is the way to go. Like, you
don't want the decision rule for
investment. You want to look at the
whole time series past, present and
future, and know the best moments to
have made the trades. I mean, there's no
comparison. You're going to do better
with the Bayesian smoothing. However,
it's just implausible computationally
and because it requires total memory of
the past and knowledge of the future.
So that's what motivates the development
of Bayesian filtering approaches,
which are tractable and calculable
through time. Yet with this
time delayed modulation,
part of the Bayesian smoothing strength
comes back into play. It doesn't enable
true anticipation of future
states, but that's what the expected
free energy does. However, the delayed
neuromodulation allows for
reconsideration of a window of past
states. And so in that way, it
corresponds to like a
slightly deeper filter,
not just a filter of a time step of one,
but a filter of like a rolling window of
five, or with some decay. And you don't
want that window to be too big because
if the window were ten minutes,
then too many contrasting stimuli
would get piled together. The Dopamine
level would just converge to a mean
field average. But there's some time
decay or time constant on the post
hoc modulation where that
neuromodulatory signal is
actually a parameter of interest.
And that's not an infinitely long or
infinitely short window, but it's some
niche dependent amount of time.
And that's a very interpretable
and first principle interpretation of
the computational role of neuromodulator
in a way that is also consistent with
all these other concordances we've been
exploring. So it's quite
an interesting connection back,
I guess in our final minutes of this
discussion.
What are you? Well,
maybe go to the beginning at the end,
which I meant to ask earlier, but it's a
good way that we can sort of close today
and look forward, which is how did you
come to this online of research
specifically studying neural networks in
this way with Karl Friston and your
colleagues?
So, yes,
so my interest was the
characterization of Barricade network.
So my first motivation is to make
biologically plausible artificial
intelligence. But to achieve that, we
need to know about biological brain or
biological neural networking.
In these several years I
collaborated with the doctor professor
Californiston to study about
his salary principle after doing forest.
My question during that
period was the
prior principle, is everything
about the biological possible
neural network? Or is theorem another
aspect that can characterize the
virus car neural network? So it is
non trivial. It was non trivial.
So that's why I
tried to start from characterizing
the neural network first. So our state
is not
considering the way of implementing any
Bayesian algorithm as the brain
architecture, but my interest
is rather characterization of a given
vertical network in terms of some
other things. One possible way is
of course based on inference free energy
transplant reinforce. So that's why I
start from characterizing power's
network. But just
defining neural network architecture is
insufficient.
Bit is not tractable, it is far beyond
the computational tractability as
the mathematical analysis and
we need some assumptions
or some trick to increase the
stability. One day I came up
with an idea that in
which we consider that both new
activity and fastest follow the
same cost function gradient.
This is very much an allergy with
physical system like Lagrangian
information or Hamiltonian formation.
So usually we consider some
energy landscape and design
plausible trajectory
as the evolution of some principle of
minimum action
or restruction. So we
imagine that what if we applied such
idea to computational
neural network or biological neural
networks to characterize thermodynamics
of the brain first
principle. That's the first
variational step to come up with this
framework.
And finally we noticed that
it is not easy to connect the Newtonian
dynamics with this type of neural
activity study because neural
activification not necessary to be a
second order differential
equation, but rather it is fast order
and considering many things.
Then we finally
use DA Costa function
proposal in the papers,
which is not necessary to have a former
identity with the so called lavalier
in the Newtonian physics,
but it is rather plausible as
the rules or underlying
mechanism of such
type of network.
Awesome. Well,
it has been quite an interesting dot
one. I really appreciate
everything you've shared today. Is there
anything else you want to add at this
point? Otherwise we'll talk again.
Yeah,
I already speak a role.
Thank you. Alright, talk to you later.
Bye. Thank you very much for a nice